just a few minutes ago we had a delivery
from Ikea of all of these boxes these
are all bookshelves which are going to
be replacing the kinds of bookshelves we
have been building so far and I am the
one who gets to put them all together so
you see my two main tools that I think
I'm gonna be needing right there and in
a moment I'm going to start opening
these up and seeing what the task ahead
of me looks like well looking at the
boxes it doesn't look like they open
these boxes open up and see what's one
looks like this is gonna be quite a task
I don't know how many of these I'm going
to do today but we shall see so a lot of
boards and
most important part the instructions so
we have eight of these
a bottom piece so now I just have to
figure out how to follow this booklet
directions and get this thing together
looking at all the pictures I figure out
all the hardware does and see what's
what so that's that so after putting in
a good three and a half hours I would
say I've got five units set up the
corner piece three this way one this way
got another one to go there and two to
go along that wall so quite a bit more
yet to do so how do I like these since
this is an unboxing video I mean they
look pretty nice
I got to say I am NOT a fan of having to
handle trim nails banged up my thumb
quite a bit trying to do that the trim
holds this in it's easy to end up
hitting the boards and that sort of
thing so it would be nice if you know
that sort of thing was marked the way
IKEA marks everything else but on the
whole you know it's not totally painless
process certainly not in a room that
small that was you know full of all
sorts of other boxes including the boxes
for these but it's some overall not too
bad you know we've got now five decent
bookshelves we can start loading books
on them which is the whole point of
having bookshelves and start getting on
with turning this into the library that
it's supposed to be so the next thing
that has to go is the bookshelf that I
built it going to disassemble that first
I gotta get all those books off of it
probably putting them
to one of these but before that we've
got to wait till Andy gets back home so
we can figure out exactly how we're
going to bracket this and if I've got
things in precisely the right places
with the underneath brackets I'm not
quite sure about that myself so you know
since we're gonna have to look at it for
quite a while better to get it right the
first time
and then in case I'm knocking off for
the day except for a little bit more to
do once once the gambia gets back here
and maybe we'll start putting some books
on these tomorrow all right these are
all the book shows that are going in
here I've already put some of my own
books that were on the other shelf there
so you can see what IKEA bookshelves
look like when you put them together
creating kind of an octagonal room
because of these middle joint
bookshelves which take up a little bit
of space but actually give us quite a
bit of bookshelf space and they don't
interfere with the room too much so this
is going to be our library and pretty
happy with the way in which the shelves
look although you've got to say looking
at it it looks like the center though
the corner bookshelves are a slightly
different shade of white than the other
bookshelves I'm not sure if that's
actually showing up here but you can see
it with the naked eye perhaps it's just
a function of the fluorescent light that
I'm using right now but it'll have to do
and I'm sure it'll look great after
we've got a lot of the books that need
to go up there on the shelves now that
all the construction is finished with
these a takia bookshelves I've got eight
units in in this room two corner pieces
and six main bookshelves I thought it
would take a little time and talk about
why having a library like this is such
an important thing for
for me and also for a woman that I
married to who's a bibliophile
unfortunate not to have somebody like
that who's supportive having an entire
room devoted to books so you know I
think for a lot of people having a lot
of books and having the the shelving for
it is really a luxury and you know you
go into many people's places and you see
a couple book shelves and you know
that's that's really about yeah and I
think that you know for for most people
that's probably pretty practical you
know you can say when you put two
academics together and two people who
really enjoy their subject matters and
who are essentially omnivorous readers
you're going to have a lot of books but
I think for me part of the reason why
I'm so happy to have all this you know
space to do this is that you know in
many of the places that I've lived that
was a possibility and I'm thinking
specifically about something that made a
huge impression on me as a kid
namely my uncle Hubert's library and my
uncle Hubert is my great uncle on my
adoptive mother's side the Larry's
family and he was a real bibliophile he
was a constant reader well the rest of
the family was doing other stuff he
would retire and read he didn't get to
go to school very long because he was
the oldest of 13 surviving children was
he the oldest no he wasn't quite the
oldest he was pretty close and so being
one of the boys he had to go off during
grade school and start working and he
just kept reading and reading and
reading and he played an incredibly
important role in my mother's generation
for getting some some kids from you know
this part of Chicago or the French
Canadians and Menominee Indians lived
and none of whom you know had thought
about going to college to go to the
library regularly and then to think
about going to call
as a matter of fact it was he and and a
few other relatives who helped my mom to
apply for DePaul and she hadn't done
that she wouldn't have met my father it
was also a first-generation college goer
who was up at the University of
wisconsin-madison at the time and you
know things wouldn't have pianned out
the way they did for not only for myself
but also for a lot of other people in
the family so uncle Hubert he was really
instrumental and when he retired he and
my grandfather and my uncle Ernie
and all of their their wives uncle
Hubert and my grandfather married two
sisters from Quebec grandma and aunt
honey and so they were very very close
as a matter of fact their houses same
house actually Wausau home same model
just slightly different colors we're
joined by a four car garage and then
uncle Ernie built his little ways away
there were actually five brothers who
talked about retiring out there in
Indiana so in any case they had a
basement and uncle Hubert put in shelves
in the basement and he put in this this
really extensive library where I spent a
lot of time as a kid because I would
stay there quite often in the summers
either at Oklahoma and Tony's or at
grandpa and grandmas later on when my
uncle Scott nantan bought uncle Ernie's
place at staying a third place but I
spent a lot of time down there in the
library that was also the common eating
place as well there was a massive
butchers table that could seat about 20
and that's where we had you know
Christmas dinners and Easter dinners and
all sorts of stuff like that just
surrounded by my books like this only
going up to the ceiling and going the
entire you know length of that room so
later on with with my inheritance
I bought uncle Hubert and aunt Tony's
house and that's where I had my office
down in that area for some time there's
a long story about you know where we're
all that's going
tell here long story short I don't I
don't you know that's not my place
anymore but I really loved having those
those bookshelves around and just being
surrounded with with volume so I knew
you know like if I want to go over here
and take one of these that's fine it was
it was a great place to work and so you
know wherever I've lived I've always
been able to put in some bookshelves and
if possible many bookshelves these are
particularly attractive and
well-designed they're not the sort of
cobbled together stuff that I typically
do just because I know much more
utilitarian about it I'm not a design
person but I'm very happy with the look
of them they set off the you know the
white sets off the books quite nicely
but so that's you know part of why for
me putting up these bookshelves is you
might say one of the first parts of
really settling in here you know there's
get the kitchen ready and get the
bathroom ready and you know find a place
where we can you know relax and get the
bedroom you know get the bed set up but
you know for somebody like me this and
having my chalkboard in my desk really
important for my my mindset about this
being a place where I'm going to get a
lot of work done so that's again a
little bit of the backstory of why
bookshelves matter to me so much so you
know all told I'd say I'm pretty happy
with these Billy bookshelves it is quite
a bit of work and you have to really pay
close attention to what you're doing I
found out the hard way and you know
they're pretty heavy to carry so if you
know if you're not all that strong
you're gonna need somebody to actually
move the boxes somewhere for you but
it's it's a manageable task and they
look pretty nice so I'm pretty happy
with them